[Music]
on this friday night russia's war plan
revealed
new objectives to dominate eastern and
southern ukraine they are trying to
threaten in order to also push nato's
edges and more evidence of atrocities
near mario paul international
humanitarian law has not merely been
ignored but seemingly tossed aside
fair trade reconciliation is not just a
word it is meant to have action and this
is an example of that action why the
iconic hbc building in winnipeg is being
handed over to local first nations earth
day and our changing landscape
a stark assessment of a planet in peril
and hope we can still save it and
tributes to canadian hockey legend gila
fleur
his larger-than-life presence on and off
the ice
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
russia is outlining new military
objectives tonight which could
effectively landlock ukraine the
announcement comes after russia claims
it's defeated ukrainian forces in
mariupol although shelling continues
there 120 000 residents are trapped
outside the war zone the u.n says there
is mounting evidence of war crimes mass
graves and an attempted cover-up but
first a look at russia's ambitions after
failing to take control of kiev and why
experts say it will be hard for
president vladimir putin to succeed
redmond shannon has our top story
tonight
good friday in the eastern orthodox
church
a blessing for easter treats prepared
for ukrainian soldiers on the front
lines
president vladimir zelinsky says russia
rejected a proposed easter truce
there is no let up around harkev the
area near ukraine's second city saw more
deadly shelling with reports in russian
media that troops seized a ukrainian
arms depot
the azov style steel works mariupol's
last holdout of ukrainian forces the
troops and civilians inside apparently
reluctant to accept a reported russian
invitation to leave with the promise of
safety mariupol's mayor again says he
believes more than 20 000 people have
already died in the city
as russia's renewed focus on the east
intensifies there are also reports that
a russian commander has stated his
army's new list of objectives to take
all of the eastern donbass region part
of which has been under the control of
russian-backed troops for eight years
to lock down a land corridor across
mariupol between the donbass and crimea
and most notably to further expand
control over the black sea coast linking
up to the long-time russian-controlled
trans-nistria region in moldova
something that would land lock ukraine
it's not an easy military operation we
see how long it takes for russians even
to take mariupol something that is right
up their nose ukrainian analyst aurissia
lucevic believes russia is ready to put
all of eastern europe on notice
rhetorically they are trying to threaten
in order to also push nato's edges and
if russia's war expands beyond ukraine
it will force nato leaders to think even
harder about what they do next redmond
shannon double news london
the evidence emerging from mario paul is
prompting international outrage with the
un saying there's evidence of war crimes
on a large scale tonight canada has
delivered more lethal aid to ukraine
including howitzer guns and anti-armor
ammunition and it's renewing calls to
expel russia from the g-20 jackson
proskow reports
each new horror revealed in ukraine
serves to further harden the west
resolve against moscow russia
does not have a place
at the table of countries
who have come together
to
maintain global economic prosperity in
washington deputy prime minister
christian freeland called for russia's
expulsion from the g20 after two days of
international finance meetings in which
canada and other nations walked out on
russian delegates support of canadian
people which we see right now is
unprecedented and for that i want to
thank you ukraine's finance minister
lauded canada's efforts including
billions in financial aid loan
guarantees and military support canada
is also discussing reopening its embassy
in kiev following the lead of several
european governments we will very
shortly
next week reopen our embassy in
ukraine's capital city
as the battle for ukraine's future rages
in the east the u.n is drawing closer to
a firm conclusion that russia has
committed extensive war crimes over
these eight weeks international
humanitarian law has not merely been
ignored but seemingly tossed assad
emerging satellite images of mass graves
in mariupol potentially for thousands of
bodies only add to what the un says are
at least 50 documented cases of unlawful
civilian executions in bucha we are very
concerned we're very worried about
what's coming next the u.n secretary
general plans to visit moscow next week
where he will meet with president
vladimir putin he may also visit keeve
he hopes to talk about what can be done
to bring peace to ukraine urgently
yet there's little optimism it will do
much to bring an end to the conflict now
that russia has made its intentions so
brutally clear
jackson prosco global news washington
one of the most iconic buildings in
western canada key to early trading and
development in winnipeg is being handed
over to first nations the historic hbc
building once the flagship of the
hudson's bay company will become an arts
and retail hub with affordable housing
and health care too brittany greenslade
has the deeply symbolic ceremony that
transferred ownership
for nearly a century this landmark
building has stood tall in downtown
winnipeg property of the hudson's bay
company
at once steeped in canadian history but
also with deep ties to western
colonization more than 350 years ago hbc
played a definitive role in the
colonization of canada
the impact of our company's history is
not at all lost on me and is part of the
reason we are all here today
and taking a step towards reconciling
the past this sprawling six-story 655
000 square foot building now transferred
from the hudson's bay company to
indigenous ownership we can agree that
reconciliation is not just a word it is
meant to have action and this is an
example of that action hbc built an
empire on fur trading it remains the
oldest retailer in north america but the
lucrative fur trade on which the
company's first fortune were built had a
major impact on indigenous people
their lands were opened to european
settlement without consultation or
consideration for indigenous sovereignty
traditional lifestyles and economy were
abandoned as many came to rely on the
fur trade to survive
now including those same pelts and hides
in the exchange of power now carries
deeper meaning
they're really addressing the racism
institutional racism that change will
come in the form of affordable housing
units office space for indigenous
entrepreneurs a health center that
combines western and traditional
medicines and a daycare where children
will be taught indigenous languages what
we're doing here is so important i know
that it's more than just today it's more
than a building it's about the people in
this building it's about the lives that
going to be impacted over the years
lives that are now reclaiming their path
forward brittany greenslade global news
winnipeg
wait times for some surgeries have been
growing in canada for decades and the
pandemic has made those lists even
longer some frontline workers say the
situation will be catastrophic without
immediate intervention but as jamie
morocco reports so far there doesn't
appear to be a clear plan
on days dr david urback is in the or he
scrubs into surgery up to seven times
but he knows all that hard work is doing
little to help ontario's massive
surgical pileup we've never seen a
backlog like this ultimately this is a
big
you know public policy risk like how do
we ensure that there's confidence in
canadian medicare and the canadian
health system canada's biggest province
estimates the waitlist has grown to
between
225 and 250
000 patients over the course of the
pandemic
jana jones was told she would have to
wait up to three years just to see a
specialist in toronto
in constant pain caused by endometriosis
the fredericton resident opted to pay
almost 40 thousand dollars to have her
operation in the u.s instead by the time
i waited that two to three years it's
hard to say
what other organs it would have been
damaging her province new brunswick is
also facing an accumulation of 22 000
patients up 10 since the pandemic
only british colombia has fewer people
waiting for surgeries compared to march
2020 down 6 percent and about 88 000
people there are at a standstill with
their treatments
in 2019 alberta did implement an
initiative to tackle its wait lists with
hopes of increasing publicly funded
surgeries contracting to private clinics
and upgrading operating rooms but kovid
put that program on hold the province
has now hired an independent official to
oversee the plan as more than 70
thousand albertans sit on the wait list
today's announcement will help repair
the damage caused to our health care
system by the pandemic the federal
government recently offered up two
billion dollars to help with the
backlogs but not a single province or
territory could tell us how they'll use
the money and most say it's not enough
when you don't have a clear plan about
where you're going what your goals are
and data and accountability within the
system to see if you're driving towards
and meeting those goals you're going to
end up with chaos provinces are mulling
over long-term solutions such as
increased staffing but that takes years
some patients just don't have what's
happening now are people are going to be
waiting uh they're going to be suffering
for long periods of time instead of
being able to enjoy a better quality of
life dr erbach hopes hospitals will take
matters into their own hands
centralizing systems and ensuring
surgeries are spread out equally among
physicians maximizing results i think
we're at a crucial junction right now
choosing the wrong path or ignoring the
problem could [ __ ] our health care
system and cost lives jamie morocco
global news toronto
starting monday the federal government
is easing more covid measures at the
border unvaccinated children aged 5 to
11 who are traveling with a fully
vaccinated adult will no longer need a
covid test to enter canada and those who
are fully vaccinated traveling with kids
under 12 won't have to provide a
quarantine plan wear a mask or report
any virus symptoms all travelers must
still use the arrive can app to upload
their travel and vaccination information
within 72 hours of arrival don't forget
that celebrating the life of a hockey
legend
all of us of my generation suddenly feel
a little bit older
today
to learn that gila fleur is no longer
with us
he was a hero
the prime minister just one of millions
of fans remembering gila floor as an
artist on the ice
and on earth day stark images of our
changing planet and what we have to do
to save it
[Music]
in arizona 30 homes and other buildings
are destroyed after a wildfire ripped
through neighborhoods near flagstaff
crews are battling half a dozen fires in
that region firefighters fear winds near
80 kilometers an hour will lead to more
catastrophic conditions this weekend
and this is what spring looks like in
calgary today a snowfall warning was
issued this morning with 10 to 15
centimeters expected saskatchewan and
manitoba are also bracing for another
spring dump this weekend up to 50
centimeters of snow expected there
manitoba has issued a flood warning for
southern parts of the province as a
result
extreme weather and our shifting climate
weighs heavily on scientists and
citizens alike the theme on this 52nd
earth day is invest in our planet a
challenge for everyone coming out of a
global pandemic here's heather yorick's
west with why the need for action is
urgent
on google's home page earth day is
marked with stark images of the climate
crisis
time satellite pictures showing glacial
retreat at mount kilimanjaro glacial
melt in greenland coral bleaching at the
great barrier reef and deforestation
across germany the reality is undeniable
earth's landscape is changing fast the
reality is
this is happening before our eyes we
know the science we understand the
reason we just have to have the courage
and the collective will to
decarbonize
canada's landscape is rapidly changing
too
take for instance the place glacier in
the south coast mountains in bc
now watch how it's disappeared since
1965. we're talking about
60 to 70 meters of lowering on the
surface of those
those ice masses in some cases and
that's that's ice that's not going to be
replenished the changing climate isn't
just melting canada's ice it's heating
up our cities as well a report out this
week from the university of waterloo
warns many canadian cities will face
more dangerous extreme heat events like
the ones in quebec and bc that claimed
hundreds of lives in recent years we
basically see that across canada there's
three zones that are particularly
exposed to extreme heat these are the
valleys of bc
the southern prairies and then the area
of the great lakes down the st lawrence
river valley when it comes to our
changing climate the news is often an
overwhelming cause for anxiety and well
bleak but scientists stress hope is not
lost there is still time to focus our
collective efforts to ensure the worst
case scenarios don't become our earth's
future reality heather urex west global
news calgary
just ahead cash for cars and why yours
might be worth a lot more than you think
if you've walked past a car lot lately
you've probably noticed a lot of empty
spaces inventory is so low prices for
used cars are reaching record highs up
48 percent over last year this week on
the new reality mike dralet reports on
the bumpy road and what's ahead for
buyers and sellers mike
it's no secret the pandemic and most
recently the conflict in europe has had
a detrimental effect on supply lines
around the world the car market in
particular is facing a major shift in
how it operates
everything is connected the automakers
can't get the parts to build which leads
to empty lots at dealerships which in
turn pushes buyers to the used car
sector where low supply combined with
increased demand has led to topsy-turvy
prices the likes of which nobody has
ever seen
one used car dealer in guelph told us a
story about a ram pickup he sold for 41
900
the guy who bought it put 80 000
kilometers on the odometer and then sold
it back to the dealer for forty four
thousand dollars the third deal for the
same car saw it sold for a fifty
thousand dollars
economists don't foresee much change
until 2023 at the earliest because the
lineup of consumers wanting a new or
used car is far too long even if auto
manufacturers operate at full speed
operate at three shifts per day seven
days a week and don't have down times
they still won't be able to fully make
up for that loss demand or that pent up
demand over the course of twenty twenty
two the unprecedented demand has opened
up opportunities for the used car
industry to adapt and offer unique
buying alternatives for consumers we'll
take you for a ride with some of those
disruptors in my report for the new
reality back to you
thanks very much mike and the new
reality airs tomorrow night at eight
o'clock right here on global
just ahead remembering one of hockey's
most electrifying players
ladies and gentlemen
invictus is heading back to north
america and this is a very very good
thing
vancouver and whistler have been
selected to host the 2025 invictus games
in partnership with four first nations
it'll be the game's first ever winter
edition more than 500 wounded and ill
military members will compete in
adaptive sports prince harry started the
invictus games back in 2013.
tributes of course are pouring in for
one of the greatest hockey players of
all time montreal canadiens legend gila
fleur has died at the age of 70. premier
francois lego says quebec has lost a
giant guillerme was a winner
he was like an artist also it was
spectacular to watch him
lego is in talks with lefleur's family
to hold a state funeral so all quebecers
can pay tribute to a hockey hero who
left a mark on an entire generation eric
sorenson takes a look back at guy
lafleur's remarkable life
in either official language
[Applause]
few fans fully appreciated the daunting
challenge lefleur faced he was a hockey
prodigy in quebec as a junior in one
season alone he scored 130 goals
he was drafted by the preeminent nhl
franchise in the history of hockey when
you're a kid your dream is to eventually
play in the nhl and to play with your
team montreal canadian because they were
the best the montreal canadiens were an
unparalleled dynasty from the mid-40s
and for 36 years the team won as many
stanley cups as all other clubs combined
from rocket richard to jean belivo to
gila floor he was expected to take up
the torch i think the expectations were
insurmountable i don't think that anyone
could have ever expected anyone to fill
the skates of jean belleville of all the
hockey heroes leflore may have carried
the greatest burden to succeed his pro
career started slowly but soon he would
flower
with hair flowing the blonde demon as he
was called in quebec would be the first
to score 50 goals and 100 points six
seasons in a row
there were too many trophies to count
coach scotty bowman once likened
lefleur's charismatic energy on the ice
to rocket richards there's only a few
that have that aura about them and and i
think he was right there that you know
you have to watch him every second this
is my family and chevrolet is my family
car
as a hockey idol the floor was featured
in commercials yes and we can get all
the help we need at zellers and as a
national icon was satirized on
television i'm gila fleur i'm daryl and
i use a daryl similar rocky stick the
floor brought particular misery to the
toronto maple leafs and to a once
unparalleled rivalry in hockey
for lefleur and the habs the
championships would keep coming five
stanley cups in his first eight seasons
on gila florist florida and the
canadians won french quebecers won
french canadians won they were
representing more than just the team
they were representing your people late
in his career lefleur retired then came
back to play for the new york rangers
and the quebec nordiques after his
playing days lafleur's life was laid low
for a time by assault charges brought
against his son and by his own health
problems
but in quebec the love and admiration
for lefleur
never lost its bloom heal a blur sends
this place into a frenzy again and he
never lost his humility or his humanity
if i look back when i was eight nine
years old i didn't expect one day to
have my sweater retired to all my
teammates
thank you very much
for the great thrill the canadians
championship dynasty lasted nearly four
decades a relay from generation to
generation and gila floor ran the anchor
league
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm chris galas and tonight
we'll leave you with the scene outside
of the bell center in montreal where
fans have been honoring the canadians
legend all day long thanks very much for
watching colleen christie will be with
you tomorrow hope you have a great
weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]